it's really not that much more money
than making videos no it's not so you
think like we're like it's just like I
don't know it's just annoying because
like I added this twice pent twenty
hours editing this [ __ ] video like on
the bus yeah and the whole time my in my
mind I'm like well I'm working so hard
on this because I want it to be great
but I also wanted to make money because
these are the most lucrative videos on
my channel yeah and then to put that up
after 20 hours of work the music I
proved the song for the whole thing like
whatever wasn't a crazy song but like it
was a lot of war effort a lot of [ __ ]
work and then I put it and just get
docked right away with the yellow thing
which didn't ease
it not only doesn't make money but it
also doesn't get shown as much that
means like can't attract new fans
you can't like yeah sure existing fans
are gonna see it they're gonna enjoy it
which I love and now I can enjoy that
video yeah well like you know all the
things that are beneficial on top of
that it's like just no longer a thing 20
hours on something it's like damn yeah
slap in the [ __ ] face I think that's
the part that blows is if you're gonna
do monetize it don't suppress it at
least yeah exactly yeah yeah yeah yeah
you let people see it yeah I mean I
guess I can talk about the low violence
I don't know if I don't know if I talked
about on the less I don't think I did
yeah I haven't talked about it because
we haven't recorded in a few weeks but
basically chewing I say is somewhere
here we go
basically yeah so I got a claim by EMI
on all the love Island videos and love
Island episode six got striked which I
think some of you have noticed so here's
the crazy part is that I used the love
island theme song for maybe 20 seconds
30 seconds and because the video was
previously determined as ineligible for
like or inappropriate for most
advertisers EMI was given the option to
strike my channel and take down the
entire video because they couldn't make
money on those 20 seconds which makes a
whack absolutely no [ __ ] sense I
don't understand how YouTube doesn't
afford the option to just remove the
[ __ ] song how does that if it's not
made any money and if it can't make
future money and all they care about is
the use of copyrighted material why do
they get to strike 15 minutes worth of
content yeah what
they're not even [ __ ] like they have
nothing to do with yeah and ever and you
know it really irks me is this morning I
saw James Charles tweeting at Sony music
being like thank you for doing the right
thing and they lifted the claim on one
of his videos so it's like alright so do
I got to be like the biggest makeup
artist to get the [ __ ] privilege is
it because like you don't know who I am
like of course yeah did you try treating
them or something
I mean in DMing them I'm just think I'm
paranoid that they go and [ __ ] the rest
of them so I'm working with Mossad and
we're gonna try to get a license to the
song and yeah it's so annoying it's so
annoying because it's like the only
thing it does the only thing this series
[ __ ] does is help though she's people
towards loved island which means more
people are listening to the [ __ ] song
because more royalties for them yeah
they not [ __ ] see that well there's
just some [ __ ] you know crony old
person who's like oh they're using our
material today yeah it doesn't it's just
so oh it's such a sucks man it's a girl
series it benefits everyone in the
[ __ ] situation yeah I gotta go [ __ ]
it all up yeah well now we got to use a
different intro song which we will make
yeah or yeah but let's just remake the
[ __ ] song that's what we should do
now I want to make our own version and
the chorus is gonna be EMI can suck our
dick yeah II and I will suck our [ __ ]
into it is it for you know whatever man
the st. the st. YouTube bitching our
it's just I mean it is but it is it is I
always say that I'm always like I you
know we'll do this and then I just do it
for 10 minutes but walking YouTube
pisses me off sometime not you know what
man here's what I'm gonna say here's the
[ __ ] here's the I think the greater
point to all this because I'll start
with this dudes tweet uh-huh
don't let Cameron Dallas or any of these
other [ __ ] influencers fool you into
thinking that Entertainment is like this
absolutely ballin experience yeah it's
not they would like access not pay their
taxes they do not abhi what it is do not
pay their taxes do cuz we're like we're
busting our asses dude in a given week
we're doing so much [ __ ] streaming
editing putting up videos doing this
podcast writing jokes making music right
live show and it's like the money's cool
yeah I'm saying I know dude but it's
definitely not enough when you see
people on on Instagram like buying these
cars
yeah not even for themselves for like
other people yeah and you're like how
how that's not it's it's you must not
pay taxes no way there's no way all
these influencers dude I feel like in a
few years or in the next like three or
four years at least we're gonna start
seeing these dudes like just
disappearing or like getting real
desperate because that's when the
[ __ ] IRS is gonna pull out and be
like yo son remember when you bought
that [ __ ] Aston Martin for the gram
yeah we needed some of that money dawg
that's not all yours yeah actually that
is yeah is ours and there's actually a
few years where you did this [ __ ] so
we're gonna need all that money back hmm
that's why I'm just I'm playing it cool
you know you know I'm not buying the I'm
not buying the Aston I'm waiting at
least a year yeah yeah wait at least ten
years before I buy that ass yeah you
know what's funny dog is all these other
influencers like they I don't even like
that word but people helped put it this
way people get a little internet money
and they go get a car they'll get a
watch they get all this dumb [ __ ] we got
a little Internet money what a week
you got some discounted off-white shoes
and I just bought a camera like that you
bought like six cameras about a couple I
spent some money on my twitch setup but
I think that's the reality dude you know
like studio - yeah yeah that's what we
did yeah that's good yeah we peel we put
the money back into the [ __ ] art but
that's they should do is is put it back
into the business
yeah you don't don't go buying the
stupid [ __ ] man oh and I and I went and
I ran through ten deeps catalog yeah
which is you know whatever I mean I
don't know I think a lot of these these
I don't know I don't want to get too
deep into it because I'm just gonna end
up [ __ ] naming names no yes I feel
I'm not I I just maybe they do pay taxes
maybe they do but I just look in the
spending habits of people that now I
know how much money there is to be made
in this industry and I got this certain
level and so like that and look at these
people I'm like you must stop paying tax
yeah Hunter Percy does not add up 100%
otherwise you're gonna have no [ __ ]
laughs yeah yeah and I think maybe the
thing that I don't know if this is
interesting to anyone you know cuz I've
actually heard people not herb of people
on twitch and if directly told me like
live that some of some people they're
into like that when they be when they
become materialistic like it gets
annoying to like consume their content
because it just becomes all about that
and I guess the thing that I would you
know tell everyone is like you know when
you see a number of like income like oh
I heard this person may ask X dollars
for this brand deal the thing you got a
factor in guys is like every single one
of us like we have a manager who takes a
fee a business manager who takes a fee
and the yeah then the [ __ ] just a lawyer
takes fees yeah yeah lawyer takes a fees
on top of that tags on top like it's
probably close to 60% them yeah yeah you
don't you know we you walk loose mm-hmm
you walk away with less than half every
time so just want you all to know that
and so the other thing like to that
point this is someone I don't have a
problem naming is I don't [ __ ] with no
feelings like rice gum who they get that
little bit of Internet money and they
just [ __ ] they flex it on their
[ __ ] audience that [ __ ] is so rude
man
yeah yeah it doesn't matter if they're
twelve or fourteen if like if they give
you that time and they build you that
platform it's like be that successful
you at least owe it to the people who
put you there to not be a douchebag yeah
yeah no I I mean I I agree but at the
same time like a lot of his audience are
there to see that flashy yeah yeah they
like seeing the supreme that all the
Gucci [ __ ] or whatever I guess like he's
actually a great example because he had
a video up that he like eventually
deleted but it was like how much money
do I make
and he showed his thing and it was like
he had it blurred out but it was pretty
clearly 60k that he made in one month
okay was a lower month for him but it
was like that that was the number 60 K
that he had made for that month yeah so
you think about that right so granted
that's a lower amount but like that's
what 600 700 K were a year highest tax
tax bracket is what 30% at least or
something like that at least plus agent
fees managed so let's say he gets home
let's say he takes home 50% of that
after the year if he pays taxes and he's
paying all of his people out yeah right
that's like 350 K yeah for a year
uh-huh he's buying a new [ __ ]
whatever car it's a $125,000 it's like
30% of your [ __ ] network later homie
buying a house not gonna [ __ ] happen
uh you got a Pam you arrived by a nice
house probably gonna pay a mortgage to
me 10 grand a month
yeah it's just it really makes sense
yeah and we're talking like LA to like
you get prepared to be [ __ ] in that
ass over taxes and just cost-of-living
flex
[Music]